I will.
Good afternoon.
Hello, Ayra, how are you?
I'm good. How about you? How is it going? Long time.
Great, great. Everything's awesome. Just loving life over here.
Yeah.
No.
Same here. Hey Andy, thanks for joining the call.
Hello, hi, Will.
Hi, Andy, how are you?
Good, how are you?
Great, thank you.
All right.
How was your Easter?
Amazing!
Yeah.
And yours was good, I hope.
Boring. I suspended working, so that's fine.
Was that? Ohh, that's not good.
That's okay.
All right, we have a new audience here. We have Justin. I'm not sure if you have met him. Will, did you?
I don't recall.
Okay, so Justin, go ahead. You can introduce yourself to William. He's our POC for outsource IT.
All right, great.
Hi, hi. Nice to meet you, William. So yeah, I'm going to be your new customer success manager and I'm going to be assisting you all throughout. I'm currently in my training phase yet, so still learning the ropes, but I'm going to be shadowing for this call and hopefully soon we'll be able to connect as well.
Nice to meet you well.
Great. Likewise. Thank you, Justin.
All right, cool. He's our new Luis, if you still remember Luis. Okay.
Okay. I do. I do.
Okay, cool. Thank you everyone for joining our monthly service call. I will be sharing my screen one second.
OK.
Let me know once you can see it.
Yu.
Here we go.
Okay, great. So today we will be discussing the review for Kelly for last month. That's March. So moving on to the agenda items, just all the same. So for this part, it's for you, Will.
We wanted to know how are things going at the moment. Any feedback, anything you want to share with us, work-related, personal, up to you.
Things are going pretty well. It's gotten a little bit busier. Not quite the uptick that I was worried about, but I'm thankful for that.
Cool. Um, how about Kelly's performance? Are we doing okay?
Kelly's performance is fine. He's doing very well still. Would like to see him a little stricter on the SOP for escalations. He's holding on to tickets sometimes a little too long before he escalates. He does eventually escalate, but I would like to see that earlier in the process.
But beyond that, he's following everything and doing what he's supposed to do.
Okay, for the SOP, do you have like a document or what's the time frame? Okay, could you share me the SOP for escalations after our call so I could review? Okay.
Yeah.
I sure will. Yeah. And it's, I guess the part I want to focus on is the escalation process that we have is maybe not standard or what he's used to. I'm not sure where he's worked before. But we don't have an escalation team that's
just sitting waiting for the escalations. We have an escalation tier that has its, has their own work that they're busy with. And so.
Once you escalate a ticket, it's not about, you know, just handing it over for review. They may not get to it that day or even the next day. So part of the SOP they would like to focus on with Kelly is you are still.
He still has to manage the ticket. When he escalates it, he's still the manager of that ticket. If he doesn't get a response, it's his duty and job to follow up and make sure that he gets in front of the escalation that's on duty. So I think he's maybe a little bit timid or maybe too trusting.
But either way, he needs to allow himself to become the pest when he has a ticket that gets escalated until he gets a response. Sometimes they're busy and whoever's on duty monitoring the escalation channel sometimes is slow to respond. Or it may get buried if they're in the middle of something else. And so
you know, at least shortly thereafter, he needs to make sure that he follows up to get an acknowledgement at the very least that the escalation has been viewed by the on-duty engineer.
Okay, thank you for the very specific guidelines on how we could escalate a ticket. And from what I'm hearing, whenever we're trying to escalate a ticket, we just need to reach out to the resource and just keep the ticket to ourselves. And we need to update it daily.
Mm.
Sure.
Right.
Oh yes, yes, yes.
Okay, so I'll wait for your document and I will review that with Kelly and we'll probably have to make our internal structure on how we're going to do that efficiently and probably have to make a document for ourselves to
Mmh.
Okay.
the resource. We can have a template saved already. So I will do that during our one-on-one for you.
All right, thank you.
Okay, you're welcome. Apart from that, is there anything else?
No, that's small beans right there. That's not a big deal, but I would appreciate some assistance with that. I've mentioned it to him a few times and we just can't, I can't seem to get that adjustment to his flow. So any help you can give would be great.
Mhm.
Okay, no worries. I'll see where he's struggling and I'll update you as well.
All right. Thank you.
Okay. Any questions so far? We can proceed. Okay. For the highlights, we have two. So far, I'm really proud that we don't have escalations from Hugh and keep on receiving positive CSAT monthly for Kelly.
No.
Yeah.
For the resolution rate, we keep, we're maintaining the 100% resolution rate for should be March, though. Please disregard that. I'll edit that later. But that's for the month of May, March. So we did have.
That's okay.
Yeah.
I'm not going on. OK, so we we have the 100% resolution rate. I believe last quarter we did have it as well, but that's what's I that's what I have noticed with his tickets. He always have 100% resolution rate.
Mmh.
Yeah.
I'm just looking at it on my end, but do you agree that that's the percentage rate is always 100?
S.
Without any data in front of me, yeah, I would say that's probably accurate, yeah.
Okay, cool. But anything, any discrepancy, please let me know for the coming slice I'm going to present you.
All right.
Okay.
For the performance analysis, for the ITBD recommended KPIs, we're already aware of this, so we can continue. For the utilization trend and analysis, so this is for four weeks, March. For the peak, we did have
Mhm.
62% utilization, that's the highest. And the dip, we did have a dip from week two, that's only 52%, but still the average was 56.75. Though our target for utilization is 80%, but we did have a discussion before that
Our target is 40%, right? But trying to figure out what else we can do so we can reach the target.
You got it, you got it. And we are making also some internal changes as far as time tracking. And so that utilization will go up as we also are starting to get, I guess, a little more granular on our tracking and a little more focused on time tracking. So currently,
We're just going to keep it where it is, but just so you know, in the coming months, we have an initiative that is coming out to better help us track time, because we know...
that there's good work being done that's not being tracked. And, you know, currently what our model is and has been in the past is not really fluffing up and tracking every minute that's not, you know, directly related to research and notes.
inside the ticket or on a phone call. But we are going to begin to initiate a push to start tracking all those extra minutes that we aren't capturing right now. So no fault to Kelly and just a heads up for you all. We are going to be
Again, to.
I guess the best way to say it is to become more strict on time tracking.
But we've not rolled that out yet. The new platform is part of that initiative, but currently the thread platform that we're using is just...
are concerned. It's just a way to introduce chat and voice agent assistant.
Okay, that's great news. I would assume that, yep, go ahead, Andy, you have a question?
Mhm.
Yeah, go ahead. You finish yours. That's fine. Go ahead.
Yeah, okay. I'm just saying that it's best that we keep everything tracked so that we know where we're struggling, right? That's it, Andy, go ahead.
Yeah.
Right.
Alright, gotcha. Thanks, thanks, Ayra. Alright, so just wanted to ask, um, William, since you guys are gonna implement this, you know, much stricter and much accurate time tracking, do you?
I think you'll be able to have like a dashboard of where we can actually see this, maybe give Ayra some sort of access to that as well, so that if it's active and if it's live, I usually check in on those dashboard for different partners as well. So if it's live, then there will be
A bit of a time wherein Ayra can coach Kelly, probably work something out whenever they do coaching session and desk side review. Do you think it's possible?
Mm.
Sure, anything's possible. I'm not sure how real time the dashboard would be. Now, Ayra, what you have now is very much a historical report that you're able to access. Are you looking for something in real time? Is that what you're asking for?
Mhm.
Yeah, probably on the tickets that they close on a daily basis, maybe, or maybe weekly.
Mmh.
Probably, if, if possible.
I guess currently, if you wanted it daily or weekly, you could always just regenerate that report, but it's definitely a manual process. It's not something that's real-time at this point.
Report.
Yeah.
Gotcha. Okay.
Yeah, from the report that William shared, I am actually using Kelly's credentials. I'm logging into his manage and that's where I can see the report. Maybe what Andrea is asking, is it like the BrightGauge access where we can see the live?
Tickets assigned to him, and if there's any SLA breach, we can see that there.
This is a breakage or any board.
No, we do not, we do not, and that that will be quite some ways away, so...
Kip.
That's okay. That's all right. I think we can work something out. I did try the ConnectWise manage in the past and they just automate an AI everything in it so that we can get the actual trend and data so that we can we can show you as well. So for now.
Okay.
Got it.
That's what we're gonna do.
Right.
Yeah, but the dashboard that Will created, it's pretty much helpful. I can see that it gets closed monthly. And yeah, apart from that, I believe he's managing it. You're doing some edits, William, right? For your dashboard. I did see some changes.
Mhm.
Yes, I don't recall what the last edit was, but I go in there once in a while and we'll tweak it a little bit.
Okay, cool. So if there's any change with your dashboard or how you track their tickets, please let me know. So probably if I can have access, that would be helpful too.
Okay.
You got it.
Okay, anything else, guys? Uh, alright.
No, I think the biggest change is going to be an integration with the phone and the time entry. So we're excited about that. So the phone calls will be integrated automatically with the total time entry on a ticket. So a lot of the, but yeah, yeah, a lot of the time.
That's nice.
that will be captured, it's not currently being captured is due to that. And you know, now it's, you know, technician will just have to kind of estimate how long was I on the call, or they may even forget to log that entirely. And of course, I see it on my side if I,
True.
If I want to go get the information, I have to go retrieve it, but unless someone is really messing up, I usually just let a busy person take care of their own and maintain their ownership of, I guess, their domain. But yeah, we're starting to integrate.
Mhm.
She.
more fully and we're excited about that.
True, I think you're not the only one having problems with that. There's a lot of engineers that has issued when it comes to tracking their time and putting accurate time entries on their tickets, because it's not about, you know, doing no work at all. It's just about ticket hygiene sometimes and putting the accurate time in it. So
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, everybody has those issues within that, within MSP. So yeah, grateful. Happy to hear it.
Yeah.
Great. Yeah, we don't want technicians to feel like they have to fluff up their numbers, because that's even more difficult to go through and find the truth. You know, I think it's ultimately going to be cleaner if we
Vishal.
True.
Ohh.
I come from the bottom up and just start adding on layers that will capture more honest time. And then if we need to fluff up from there, I guess we'll have to eventually one day. But yes, we don't like fluff because it's too easy.
Mhm.
I mean, it's not hard to get to 80%. You know, if I became a monster and yelled at people, it would be 80%, but it wouldn't be any different as far as work hours in a day. It would just be fluff on paper. So we're not interested in that. We want close to actual time, so we know.
Yeah.
Mhm.
what the real numbers are. That way we can continue to...
I guess provide the type of service that they're aiming for.
Gotcha. Appreciate that. Oh, by the way, since we're on the topic of utilization, as for your local guys, are they getting kind of like the same average for utilization with Kelly? Gotcha. Okay, cool. I just wanted to make sure that, you know, Kelly's not behind or in any way, shape, or form. And just in case he is.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah.
Mm.
He, he has all the help that he needs as well.
Yeah.
Hey, no problem. And if you wanted to, Ayra, that report I gave you, if you wanted to change the name on it, you can change the name to some of the other texts and see what their numbers are.
Yeah, yeah, I can see them there.
What?
Yeah.
Kour.
Okay.
Good to hear.
Okay, moving on to the ticket closure trend here. So as we were discussing earlier, he did have the 100% resolution rate for the entire month. So I checked his dashboard and most of his tickets were focused on troubleshooting.
Mhm.
like for end user computing printers, emails, and so on. So the average per week, the ticket closure is 21 percent. So that's a good number for Kelly. Okay, moving on.
Mmh.
See ya.
There. For the way forward, we have three. So Kelly is still trying to complete the Apple technician certification. I know I did promise you last month that he's going to be completing it, but then he did ask for some more time. He did
try to complete or the he did try the practice test twice and he did nail it but then he wanted to make sure that for for the actual exam he will he will pass it. So we are currently allowing him to borrow our MacBook.
Mmh.
So most of the time he's using that for training. And he's also adding one hour time entry for the training, if that's okay with you.
Good.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, okay. And for the upcoming holiday for ITBD by Design, we have on May 1, the Labor Day. Do you guys celebrate this as well? Or do you need Kelly to work?
EE.
No, we're off that day as well.
Okay, cool. I'll have, I'll have him add that too.
OK.
Mhm.
Okay.
No, no, no promises, like always.
I mean, I will check in, but they really are difficult to nail down.
You think there's a...
PH.
Gotcha. Do you think, was there, was there any time that they've joined the QBR in the past?
No, they they they they are quite used to.
Okay.
That's not promising, Will. Come on.
Oh, I know it. I know it. But it's honest. So I could blow smoke in your face if you want. That's easy. But yeah, they just...
Mhm.
This is easy.
Good.
They're just, they're just not going to come. I mean, I keep telling them and I do relay when I tell you, I relay, I do. And I don't blow it off. You know, I let them know that, hey, it'd be really great if you were on the next one. But I can see the eyes glaze over and I'm just like, yeah, that's a no.
Atul.
Mhm.
Yeah.
That's a no.
I gotcha. Yeah, if that happens and that's the usual response, then I'll just talk to Justin and Natalie so that we can just proceed with the QBR so that we actually understand what what's what we were able to achieve for the past quarter and what were what's going to happen in the next few.
Okay.
Sure.
of course, with this partnership as well. So yeah, I appreciate your trying, reaching out, William. I appreciate that. We'll let you know when would be the next schedule of the QBR so that we can send out an invite also.
I.
Sure.
PH.
Okay.
You got it.
Yeah, but if we're going to track it should be June, this coming June.
Okay.
Okay, moving on for the team GPS, so you already know this. So if in case you're interested to implement this within your team, so you can actually book meetings, exchange points, kudos, you can track scorecards and everything.
as well as for other ITBD products we have. So in case you're interested in some of them, you can reach out to Justin.
Okay.
And for the open Q&A, any questions, Team? Anything you want to say before we wrap up the call?
Nothing for me.
Mm.
Nope, not really. Oh, by the way, probably just a question when it comes to the certification of Kelly William. I think he did mention that he tried to
Mmh.
attend and take his test and then he initially failed at it. So I wanted to know if the certification is actually required for him to actually work on those tickets maybe.
Mhm.
No, no, it's not. So, we have the majority of our users are Windows. We do have a small portion of Mac users, so it's...
Okay.
Mhm.
you know, instead of having to avoid this tech for a Mac or that tech for a Mac, we like that they all at least have some type of basic knowledge where they can, yeah, where they can triage and if they need to pass it up the ladder, they can do that. But just a basic.
Understanding.
Kour.
Mmh.
you know, Mac certification, just so that he has the awareness. But I mean, minus the actual certificate, he's at least now seems to have the knowledge that he needs in order to function at that basic level.
Mhm.
Yeah.
True.
Yeah, yeah, I guess, I guess now at this point, it's like, you know, why not just take the test so you can become certified and then, you know, maybe he can expand his horizons because I'm sure he's not going to be with Outsource forever. But, you know, the more certifications you get, the more options you have in the future. So it's like.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Do we want the certification so one of our techs has it so we can brag about it? Sure. But, you know, from a managerial standpoint, I also want him to have it because, you know, it'll help him with whatever next chapter he goes to.
Mhm.
So yeah.
True. He actually tried once. Him and I had a skip level, and he did mention that he tried it once. Unfortunately, he failed, but it's like 12 points to the passing grade, really. So he's really studying to take it again. But I just wanted to make sure that, you know, he actually understands the concept of it.
Good.
which he does, I believe so. I think he mentioned that he just overthinks a few questions because it's scenario based. So sometimes if you're there, you do not, if you have a lot of choices, sometimes most of them make sense. So you don't actually know which one to answer.
Yeah.
Good.
But yeah, he's still prepping, but you know, we'll let you know what will be the result in the next couple of weeks. And then hopefully he gets it. Hopefully, because it's not a cheap certification, man. It's quite expensive for him also.
Right.
All right.
And.
Yeah.
So.
Yeah, and yeah, so whatever we can do also to help with that, just, you know, just let us know.
Mm.
Uh-huh.
Sure, we'll do that. He has, I think, some focus time in reviewing and trying different stuff on Mac. So if we need anything or if he needs anything from your side of the fence, we'll let you know. I'm pretty sure he would, but yeah, we'll let you know also.
Mm-hmm.
OK.
Yeah.
Right, and as far as testing goes, we reimburse for any certification test that is passed. So, if you know, once he once he passes that, we'll reimburse him for that, or I don't know if it goes to...
All right.
Mhm.
Yes.
Yep.
ITBD or if it goes to trade to Kelly, I don't know.
It.
Should be Kelly, yes, it would be reimbursed through Kelly. So part of the process also for the partnership, he needs to pass it. And then after that, we'll send you the invoice, you pay it, and we reimburse it. So.
Okay.
Mm.
Awesome. Thank you.
No problem. Yeah, I think that's the pending one, but yeah, we'll keep you posted.
Do you have anything else?
Okay.
Perfect, thank you. No, that's it.
All right, perfect, Ayra.
Okay, thank you for that one, Andy, for bringing that up. So we appreciate that you're willing to pay for the practice exam as well. So that's good news. I'll let him know about it. And for the pending item for me, I'll make sure to reach out to him regarding the escalation process. So if
Well, you could share the SOP anytime.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you. So that's all for me. Thank you so much everyone for joining our monthly service call and see you next month.
I will.
See you. Take care everyone. Bye bye. Bye bye.
Take care. Bye-bye.
I will. Thank you.
PH.
Hey, Justin.